laissez-moi vous parler d'un produit qui
est un indispensable pour la maison
aujourd'hui qu'est le pixel pixel
tablette alors si vous regardez ma
chaîne youtube vous savez que je suis
déjà un amoureux d'une estomac qui est
un produit que j'ai utilisé pendant très
longtemps à la maison et qui est juste
là qui est en haut un produit tout en un
pour venir piloter sa maison
intelligente vous le prenez lorsque vous
l'utilisez pas et bien il fait 4 photos
et puis après vous avez plein d'options
qui sont supracool et super intelligente
pour venir à piloter votre maison alors
vous allez son relaxant vous avez la
météo vous avez plein de trucs pour
venir contrôler votre maison ici allumer
vos lumières et ça ne veut lumière votre
caméra votre pièce et compagnie bref le
contenu multimédia c'est un objet très
complet jouer déjà présenté il est là il
est beau il est sympa j'aime beaucoup et
alors là Google a sorti à notre produit
qui est juste génial et bien c'est ça
c'est la pixel tablette et alors cette
pixel tablette elle ressemble quand même
vachement honnête c'est-à-dire que vous
avez cette espèce de gros dock alors un
peu moins gros bien évidemment on le
voit ici là qui est quand même un peu
plus discret alors il y a toujours un
câble attention ici il est quand même un
peu plus discret que est-ce que j'ai
assez de longueur de câble j'espère que
oui que sur le nestomax mais pour autant
vous avez quand même ça et alors comme
ils appellent ça une tablette et bien
vous prenez vous enlevez et vous avez
votre tablette à la main alors la
tablette moi j'ai une coque dessus que
j'ai rajouté qui est dans ce truc là
normalement c'est la pixel case et la
pixel case allez quand même pas mal du
tout parce que elle a un truc qui est
vachement cool c'est à dire que vous
êtes espèce de petite anneau derrière
vous l'ouvrez et vous la posez comme
vous voulez donc je peux la poser comme
ça je peux la poser comme ça je peux la
poser complètement à plat la poser même
dans ce sens là si je le souhaite bref
ça me permet vraiment d'en faire tout un
peu un peu tout ce que je veux alors moi
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi est-ce
que j'adore cette pixel tablette alors
je tiens à préciser une fois de plus ce
n'est pas une vidéo sponsorisée on
m'envoyait c'est Google qui m'a envoyé
le produit en mettant le gros est-ce que
tu veux le tester je veux dire eh ben
ouais mon mon beau Google j'adore ça
donc ils me l'ont envoyé je l'ai à la
maison depuis quelques jours et c'est un
produit qui se trouve très très cool il
y a des petits trucs qui me chiffonne
ent un peu au nestum max mais dans
l'ensemble
c'est un produit hyper chouette vraiment
basé sur l'utilisateur et sur l'usage de
la maison connectée on est sur une
tablette mais façon Google et c'est ça
qui est intéressant allez on y va
alors je reprends pour vraiment resituer
je vais vraiment mettre ces deux
produits face à face parce que pour moi
il se ressemblent énormément à savoir
que lorsque vous les avez regardé on va
venir filmer avec ça ce sont quasiment
les mêmes produits se ressemblent dans
la différence qu'on va avoir c'est que
le nestomac va être situé un peu plus
haut par rapport à la pixel tablette
dans les deux cas ils vont faire revivre
vos photos ça c'est chouette vous avez
un grand écran d'un côté de l'autre des
bords qui sont un peu plus fins sur la
pixel tablette que sur le nestum max une
caméra qui est un peu plus proéminente
qu'on voit un peu moins ici et puis je
vous dis elle est un peu plus surélevée
par rapport à l'autre sinon dans
l'ensemble c'est quasiment un peu la
même chose vous les mettez de profil il
faut dire quand même qu'ils sont venus
un peu revoir le design avec la pixel
tablette qui est un peu plus fine très
sympa et qui de derrière également est
assez joli alors vous le voyez la
première différence ça se situe derrière
il y a les super important pourquoi et
bien parce que son estomax j'ai ce petit
bouton là et ce petit bouton là il sert
vraiment à quelque chose il sert à venir
désactiver la caméra et désactiver le
micro ce que je n'ai pas ici là j'aurais
absolument aucune alors on va pas
forcément utiliser la pixel tablette un
estomac parce que comme son nom
l'indique est bien il y a pixel dedans
il y a pas de nest donc on n'est pas
dans la même idée de la surveillance
comme on a avec le nestum max vous voyez
c'est un peu le truc qui tout de suite
me fait dire ah c'est quand même un
produit quand même différent et qui
vient pas raconter exactement la même
histoire cette pixels tablette elle est
quand même super canon elle est super
canon pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison c'est que vous pouvez utiliser de
deux manières différentes la première
manière je vous dis c'est sur son son
hub comme ça son doc son doc on va dire
son énoncé fonctions hub sur un doc
c'est ça vous le posez sur son doc et là
c'est cool alors c'est cool pourquoi
déjà parce que vous avez des
haut-parleurs intégrés ici qui ont un
volume qui est quand même vachement plus
couillu que si vous venez l'écouter
autrement je vous mets un peu de son
vous avez tout de suite comprendre
écoutez ça vous allez des graves vous
avez des beaux aigus c'est assez rond et
vous allez voir lorsque je vais
l'enlever vous êtes prêt on y va
c'est un peu plus près tout de suite le
spectre diminue ça se compacte c'est
très sur le médium je remets
plus du tout la même chose je vais
mettre fort vous allez voir écoutez
encore
et c'est là où on va vraiment tout
l'intérêt de ce dock c'est à dire que
vous avez ce haut parleur à l'intérieur
qui envoie beaucoup plus de son qui a
beaucoup plus de rondeurs qui est
beaucoup plus jolie et qui ira
parfaitement bien est-ce que vraiment
ici vous recommande donc ça c'est le
premier truc donc ce dock il sert déjà à
ça il sert bien évidemment à le tenir à
le poser alors moi je vous le dis chez
moi il est positionné dans ma cuisine
j'aime bien avoir en face de moi si je
veux un bout de recette si je veux
regarder un truc pendant que je cuisine
si je veux des informations et puis
après je la prends je l'embonne et j'en
fais ce que je veux mais je la position
centrale c'est la cuisine parce que la
cuisine c'est un lieu de vie c'est là où
j'avoue c'est revoir des photos c'est là
où j'aime choper quelques petites
informations mais on peut également
permettre dans son salon parce que il y
a un truc à faire Google qui est super
malin c'est que bien évidemment et bien
ils sont venus intégrés sur la home
alors après vous le mettez vous le
mettez pas et bien Google TV alors ça ça
m'intéresse pourquoi parce que je vois
un peu des des programmes que je peux
venir retrouver sur Disney plus sur pas
mal juste après je peux venir ouvrir
Google TV si directement par exemple si
vous regardez Mandalorian ici sur Google
TV sur disney+ et bien je clique là je
vois ok alors je vois que j'ai une télé
à proximité en bas donc si je la
regarder sur ma télé et bien j'ai juste
à venir à cliquer ici ça va venir me
proposer alors non ça c'est ça ne leston
max ou sur la TV du salon je clique
dessus je regarde sur la TV du salon et
ça me l'envoie directement quand c'est
quand même vachement bien sinon je fais
regarder maintenant sur Disney plus j'ai
mon application à disney+ donc ça
m'ouvre directement ici sur le compte
alors après j'ai l'autre petite
télécommande ici j'appuie dessus hop là
ça va venir me rechercher je retrouve ma
télé du savon du savon dans du salon et
puis de la même manière j'ouvre
l'application Google TV où je vais venir
retrouver tout ce que je veux si par
exemple voyez il y a un truc sur France
TV je clique là j'ai pas l'application
francetv regardez maintenant sur France
TV ça me propose d'installer
l'application France TV que je sais pas
pour me dire consulter ce contenu donc
c'est Google TV c'est un agrégateur de
contenu intelligent ici et qui fait son
taf une fois de plus sur cette Google
tablette pixel tablette pardon donc ça
c'est un des premiers points forts c'est
vraiment l'expérience 100% Google qu'on
vient retrouver ici une fois de plus
c'est l'idée ça dégoogle vous prenez les
pixels aujourd'hui que vous preniez
pixel fun je veux dire les smartphones
vous prenez cette tablette là et bien
l'idée c'est d'avoir notre système
complet construit uniquement enfin pas
uniquement mais vraiment construit
principalement autour des usages que
Google pense être les meilleurs pour
vous simplicité de connexion à la Maison
du divertissement très facilement vous
avez pareil de la même manière un jeu on
se prend un asphalt 9 vous l'ouvrez il
est totalement optimisé pour venir jouer
alors là je l'ai posé sur le doc mais je
l'enlève du doc je le prends à la main
et je peux jouer très facilement à mon
asphalt 9 c'est pareil c'est un des gros
points forts qu'on vient retrouver ici
et ça marche du feuille de Dieu c'est
extrêmement rapide c'est ludique c'est
cool ouais je vais pas vous faire la
démo de asphalt 9 on s'en fout parce
qu'on connaît déjà à ce 29 mais après
pour trouver votre maison connectée par
exemple moi je suis tout en Philippe
Sioux à la maison je clique là Philippe
Siou j'aime les pièces j'ai mon truc
j'allume je déplace parce que je veux
c'est pratique mon roborock qui est là
je peux suivre ma consommation d'énergie
je peux écouter de la musique ici bref
c'est super malin et puis si vous avez
plein de produits Google moi j'ai dit
Google nest of max j'ai du Google nest
et bien vous pouvez utiliser par exemple
votre pixel tablette pour venir parler
façon interphone dans la maison pour
dire le repas est prêt comme moi dans la
cuisine par exemple et là on démarre on
vient manger parce qu'on a hyper faim
donc c'est vraiment un produit qui
trouve sa place dans l'intérieur pour
une famille alors si vous êtes seul chez
vous vous vivez seul c'est pas grave il
y a pas besoin d'appeler tout le monde
la planète terrephone pour faire des
visions vous faites avec votre caméra là
vous avez également une caméra de 8
mégapixel à l'arrière qui à mon avis ça
servira quand même à beaucoup moins de
choses que la caméra que vous avez avant
mais si vous voulez venir converser avec
des amis faire du Google meet à venir
échanger vous pouvez le faire et vous
avez une fois de plus tout ce que Google
propose ici à savoir YouTube musique le
drive va venir stocker vos données à
droite à gauche bref c'est pour moi un
produit qui est juste top dans la maison
connectée dès lors que principalement
pour qu'il y ait un intérêt que vous
soyez un aficionado de Google et que
vous utilisiez les services Google que
vous avez c'est encore mieux un Google
pixel pour votre smartphone que vous
puissiez effectivement utiliser c'est
beaucoup plus simple c'est beaucoup plus
clair comme ça tout est vraiment bien
câblé ensemble si en plus de ça vous
avez une caméra de sur une caméra nest
ça va encore mieux mais vous pouvez
venir tout connecter avec à tout un
écosystème qui vient scanner dessus sans
aucun problème donc c'est là où est la
force de Google ici à prix autre petit
détail si je vais par exemple sur
Youtube là vous voyez hop là pose mon
doigt je lève légèrement vers le haut ça
m'ouvre le petit doc je clique là j'ai
accès à mes applications donc je trouve
qu'il y a un truc d'un point de vue
logiciel qui a été super bien pensé qui
est extrêmement pratique revenir
utiliser vos Google très facilement et
alors après je vous le dis vous mettez
dans une pièce vous pilotez la maison
vous conversez vous êtes connecté avec
des amis et puis le moment où vous dites
allez arrive le soir et je veux aller me
poser je vais me regarder un film une
série vous prenez vous laissez le doc
alors ça avec bon tout seul là comme ça
c'est pas ce qu'il y a de plus beau mais
bon vous laissez votre doc vous prenez
votre tablette et vous vous regardez un
film sur Molotov une série sur Netflix
par exemple le truc qui est cool c'est
que si vous utilisez la pixel case et
bien vous pouvez venir l'ouvrir et vous
le posez il se met comme vous voulez
alors le seul truc c'est que si vous
vous mettez sur un lit posez-le vraiment
sur une surface plane si c'est sur vos
jambes avec ça ça risque de bouger c'est
pas ouf ouf mais sinon je trouve que le
système est quand même plutôt pas mal
fait alors ce qui est aussi bien c'était
comme ça c'est renvoyé comme ça derrière
ça vient se mettre directement et
l'aimant est très fort donc il se pose
il se cale il bouge pas ce qu'on aurait
pu aimer alors bon voilà dans un monde
idéal c'est de pouvoir le retourner pour
l'avoir à la verticale personnellement
ça me dérange pas c'est déjà pas mal de
pouvoir l'avoir à la verticale grâce à
ce système là je le prends je le pose je
l'ai à la verticale pour venir aller sur
Instagram pour aller sur TikTok pour
venir regarder des vidéos comme ça ça
fonctionnera mais sur le doc ça
fonctionne pas et puis après vous avez
vraiment ce que Google fait lui
aujourd'hui c'est la puce G2 la peine
sort G2 de Google avec la puce de
sécurité Titan m2 vous avez 8 Go de RAM
alors il existe une version 128 Go de
stockage ou 256 comme on est chez Google
on est quand même plus à l'utiliser avec
beaucoup de services dans le Cloud donc
pour moi le 128 déjà globalement il y
aura très bien alors il y a une seule
taille d'écran c'est du 11 pouces qu'on
a là mais une fois de plus c'est un
format qui me semble être pas mal on
n'est pas sur une tablette qu'on va
vouloir prendre comme un iPad Pro vous
voyez très grand format où on se dit ok
je veux vraiment le plus grand format et
je veux pouvoir travailler avec elle on
peut venir travailler avec si on fouette
on a une tablette sur Android il y a
aucun problème là-dessus mais pour moi
l'idée c'est plus la notion de
divertissement et de famille alors après
rien ne vous empêche de venir prendre un
petit clavier Logitech pour venir
travailler dessus si vous le souhaitez
mais pour moi c'est pas trop trop l'idée
l'idée c'est plus une fois de plus le
divertissement familial alors après
petites choses qui est intéressant vous
venez ici dans vos paramètres vous avez
un petit mode hub ici où vous allez
pouvoir activer votre économiseur
d'écran vous paramétrer dans les photos
de Google que vous avez pris il y a
plein de choses vous choisissez ce que
vous voulez un aperçu avec les aléates
l'assistant et compagnie que vous
trouvez là l'écran de verrouillage
confidentialité domotique bien
évidemment l'assistant Google qui est là
et puis après on est sur un Android très
un an qu'on a accès à toutes les infos
qu'on souhaite ici avec le système les
services Google sécurité confidentialité
pour une recherche et les dernières
mises à jour l'autonomie qui est plutôt
bonne parce qu'en fait la question
l'autonomie elle vient pas trop trop se
poser là-dessus parce que comme c'est un
produit qui va être très souvent sur son
doc et bien vous allez pas vous dire ah
est-ce que je suis chargé par les
charger en fait quand vous avez fini de
l'utiliser pour regarder un film une
série par exemple ce soir vous le
reposez vous mettez sur le doc et il
charge donc il y a pas de problème de
d'autonomie là-dessus autre sujet que je
trouve vraiment intéressant c'est que
lorsqu'il est éteint alors vous avez le
bouton ici pour venir l'allumer pointe
qui est un peu planqué là avec la coque
de protection et le bouton de volume
sinon c'est tout ce que vous avez
lorsque vous êtes comme ça et que vous
voulez venir le déverrouiller alors vous
venez le lever et lui il vous l'indique
en fait ici vous indiquez une petite
flèche qui vous dit oh c'est par là que
ça se passe donc là vous posez votre
doigt hop là capteur d'empreinte
digitale et ça déverrouille ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point qui est
super intéressant ce que vous voulez
venir déverrouiller et bien c'est qu'en
fait vous avez le choix entre
différentes sessions là par exemple j'ai
la mienne mais je peux venir mettre
celui par exemple de de Justine à la
maison je pourrais éventuellement mettre
un compte pour Eliot et alors je peux me
dire déverrouiller par code ou alors
avec l'empreinte digitale ça
déverrouille très très rapidement ça
c'est quand même très très bien ce qui
fait qu'en fait et que lorsque vous le
posez dans une pièce de vie et bien tout
un chacun peut avoir accès directement à
ses propres paramètres à ses propres
applications il y a sa propre expérience
Android personnalisée très facilement
donc c'est pareil c'est un petit détail
mais ça fait partie de l'expérience
logiciel qui pour moi est très bien
cette tablette elle est pas destinée
uniquement à un seul membre de la
famille mais vraiment à l'ensemble de la
famille dès lors qu'ils ont un compte
bien évidemment Google et qui est
paramétré sur cette tablette avec ses
pixel tablette vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous faites avec une tablette
Android et vous pouvez faire tout ce que
vous faites avec un Google Nessma
quasiment donc on est vraiment sur une
tablette qui a la croisée des chemins
non pas sur un usage professionnel pour
venir travailler bien que on puisse le
faire parce qu'on peut faire du
multitage peut m'y faire de glisser
déposer de photos mais c'est pas le
sujet pour moi c'est vraiment une
tablette qui va trouver sa place dans un
espace de vie dans la famille où tous
les membres de la famille vont pouvoir
venir l'utiliser à tour de rôle vous
avez bien évidemment tout le Play Store
avec toutes les applications qui sont là
et qu'on peut venir utiliser très
facilement alors pour installer plein de
jeux dessus comme on est bien évidemment
sur une telle sort G2 de Google c'est
pas la plus la plus puissante par
rapport à l'instant dragon 8 gène 2 mais
pour autant en fait on est quand même
vachement de jeu sans aucun problème
donc en termes de divertissement on a
vraiment ce qu'on veut donc je vous le
dis on est vraiment sur une tablette
familiale que je trouve bien donc si
vous êtes une famille si vous cherchez
une tablette pour la famille même entre
coloc si vous aimez partager la notion
du partage d'objets connectés à la
maison intelligent vous va avec en plus
ce côté cadre photo pour moi c'est
vraiment un objet génial et je vous le
dis il a trouvé toute sa place chez moi
d'ailleurs il va y rester parce que je
l'aime beaucoup alors j'aime beaucoup
mon estomac mais pour autant je vais pas
le remettre dans la cuisine là où je
l'avais mis avant et ou pareil j'avais
un peu cet usage là je vais voir où je
vais le mettre je sais pas encore ça me
perturbe parce que il avait une place de
choix aujourd'hui il a une place
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires est-ce que
c'est vraiment une tablette qui pourrait
vous aller qui pourrait vous plaire
surcharge en usb-c sinon si vous voulez
l'emmener en voyage et que vous voulez
cette doc là après les manches je vous
l'ai dit il est quand même relativement
fort ne cherchez pas le tirer comme ça
ça sert à rien vous le prenez vous
appuyez légèrement hop vous voyez ça se
retire tout seul en fait je prends
j'appuie ça se déclipse ça part c'est
génial j'adore voilà donc à vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires et si elle vous intéresse
vous connaissez l'histoire vous avez dit
dans la description je vous embrasse à
bientôt Ciao